okay so thanks organizers for putting
the meetings to get meeting together we
will talk about a class of questions
which I would call time series analysis
or classical questions and I would like
to use a matter of matrix estimation to
solve these questions as the talk will
progress I'll make it clear what
questions I'm talking about in the
context of time series analysis and in
case you have not looked at the matrix
estimation method I am currently a big
fan of that it's a fantastic method
that's out there there's been utilized
developed collectively in over the last
decade or so and I will describe that in
briefly and then we'll put these two
things together as a part of the talk
this is based on joint work with three
of the students at MIT and those are the
papers associated with the talk ok so
let's start with just a sample questions
to explain what these time series
analysis questions are so I'm going to
talk about questions from retail because
I've been close to retail over the past
couple of years and I think retail is
fascinating at least right now so here's
one question so let's think of a Target
store in sunny well initially I was
going to think of Target store in Palo
Alto and then I realized that sounds
like a wrong thing so it's a Target
store in the Sunnyvale and there is one
in Sunnyvale by the way and and it's
nice weather like here and you're
selling umbrellas in that store most
likely those umbrellas are selling
hardly selling first of all and maybe
when it was rain like last week it could
be there was a surge in umbria sell and
then maybe
there were four umbrellas on on shelf
and because there's too much rain all of
them got sold out and then a few days
where you don't have any demand recorded
because they're no umbrellas available
on self so if actually what's happening
is that you got a few every let's say
every week you're observing some number
of transactions of umbrellas sell and
these are integer numbers they're
censored this hence you might have lots
of missing values and what makes sense
as an underlying model is some kind of
there is a latent demand or latent rate
that's changing over time okay what you
want to do is that you were estimate a
rate like that there's an underlying
hidden structure from this kind of
extremely noisy data another question
well now that you've sort of estimated
what happened in past maybe you want to
predict what's going to happen in future
maybe there's a trend maybe there's a
seasonality maybe there is a some kind
of a stationarity or combination of all
of that and then finally if you are
somebody who is providing solutions to
these retailers and you say hey you guys
should use my policy whether that policy
for mobile check out if you call it or
if it's a policy saying that this is how
you should stock your inventory or what
not at the end of the day I would say
well I'm gonna give you these amazing
decision rules because of which your
revenues are going to go up and then the
your customer in this case target will
say well I'm not sure actually your
policy is going to make any difference
to me actually it might ruin my thing
and then now it's a onus is on you to
prove to them that no no actually it's
going to work well they said okay that
sounds fine what I'll do is I'll create
two copies of Sunnyvale Target store and
one I will run the policy and another I
will not run the policy and as you are
listening to this they say well that
doesn't make sense because there's only
one Target store in Sunnyvale so then
the question is that how do you do deal
with this kind of question it's like
same the question sort of whether a
given policy like gun control is going
to reduce the crime rate or not in
California well then no to California's
it's not like classical randomized
control so you need to somehow create a
control out of thin air and as
economists this is a bill
topic and especially in econometrics has
been studied more so in last decade or
so under the umbrella term called
synthetic control and their basic ideas
that well yes
Sunnyvale is only one store but maybe
there is another store in Mountain View
which there is which is almost like
Sunnyvale so maybe let's implement a
policy in Sunnyvale and not implement
policy in Mountain View and then see
what the differences are or a
combination of that and the question is
how do we do that in a data-driven
manner is what's a really interesting
set of questions so anyways these are
the three questions that I want to
consider in this job and just to
summarize right really on one hand I'm
trying to understand that there is some
notion of state that is hidden or latent
that's evolving over time and I want to
estimate that when observations are
extremely noisy like I got an nosey
Poisson noise for example or me and /or
missing values in question how do I
recover that in addition to just
recovering the unknown state can I
predict what's going to happen there's a
forecasting and then finally the third
thing is how do you think about
synthetic control so those are the three
questions any questions about the
questions
okay all right so so those are the three
questions at the time series analysis
part of the title and now I'm going to
talk about matrix estimation and this is
something most of us have seen I'm just
going to quickly do level set I'm going
to walk through that one way to think
about classical matrix completion or
Netflix recommendation question is that
you've got users you've got movies
you've got a bunch of ratings between
users and movies that are observed and
lots of them are not observed and what
you want to do is that you want to
estimate the missing values and /or you
know actually denoise the observed
values and that's basically a matrix
estimation problem putting it other way
there is some ground truth underlying
matrix a that you want to estimate so
that your error is small and to estimate
this the observations you have is a
factor let's call it a matrix Y where
the entries Y IJ has something to do
with a IJ and not all of them might be
observed okay so in a sense you've got a
noisy version noisy plus missing value
of matrix and from that you want to
recover the original matrix okay so
that's basic matrix estimation problem
here is a generic model that's useful to
encompass a large class of things that
are done in this literature on one hand
the classical matrix completion question
in the context of recommendation system
or stochastic block model for community
detection or griffons more generally or
effector models that economists think
about for things like synthetic control
and the list goes on okay so all of
those things if actually boil down to
this kind of nice clean simple model
where the model says that every row and
every column of your matrix has some
hidden features let's call it X 1 I and
X 2 J the ground truth that you want to
estimate is again some latent function
applied to these latent features that's
AI J so the function is consistent
across all entries and in a sense matrix
is now parameterize by these
row column features and observations
that you have which is why I J is such
that you don't know the distribution but
you know that in expectation it is a IJ
and usually in this literature one would
assume that the weii JS across i JS are
independent if it's a classical matrix
completion literature one would say that
y IJ is a IJ plus additive symmetric
symmetric noise with zero mean or if
it's a graph on setting then you would
say well why i j is 0 or 1 with
probability a IJ etcetera etcetera okay
and there's a great sets of reasons why
this is very good model again then given
this setting what you want to do is that
you want to understand under what
structure on the function feature space
and the amount of data you observe you
can actually produce a consistent
estimator okay any questions about the
matrix estimation is a question and
there are roughly two types of things
again this is little more detail than
what I want to talk about at least for
the purpose of this talk but
highest-level either it's additive or
this is a generic noise and the purpose
of this table is to say that there is
lots of nice work that's done or passed
a decayed like and these are there's a
extremely large literature it's like I
could sort of just keep talking for the
rest of the session
but I'm just putting out for each pair
of noise model and function class where
the best sample complexity is known for
able this is by Kevin mountain Arian oh
that's by Chatterjee those two are by
some of me and my collaborators okay but
the point that I want you to take away
from this is matrix estimation is re at
a reasonable place where there are good
algorithms that are out there and we do
understand the threshold ins sample
complexity reasonably well and the main
point of the talk is ever all
three questions that I spoke about in
the beginning there's a time series
analysis question that is estimating
latent state forecasting the state and
producing a good synthetic control all
of them can be solved by a matrix
estimation so for the purpose of talk
I'm gonna assume that there is a nice
black box method which is good matrix
estimation method and what I want to do
is really I want to show you how each of
these problems can be viewed as a matrix
estimation problem with that let me just
get onto there in the details of it
okay so first is what I would call a
time series imputation and again it's an
imputation because there's a latent
structure that I don't I'm not observing
because of noise or because of missing
value are both and hence I'm trying to
impute it or interpolate it putting
another and here's depending on how you
look at it at least this one way to do
time series analysis and economics
literature which is well this is at
least right now at is for for me among
my colleague that's where the home is
for this the standard practice would be
well you look at your time series data
and you say well let me see if it's
stationary or not it's not stationary
let me find out non stationary component
one way to find that out or remove that
is to fit some kind of a sparse
polynomial basis to that and get rid of
it once I'm done with that so now I'm in
world of stationarity but then I have a
world in stationarity and periodicity so
let me get rid of periodicity and then
finally I'm done with that let me go to
some form of stationarity and then sort
of layer by layer I'm going to take the
my data peel them off they're all good
tests around it to sort of determine how
to stop and so on but there's a some
human intervention but at the end of it
you come up with a nice model and that's
effectively what a good our library
package for time series analysis would
do and for the purpose of all the
results I'm going to state I'm going to
assume that underlying function
F that's of interest index by T is one
of these models or combination of that
yes any questions F of T is my interest
I'm going to recover it and my
observations are these random
observations X of T okay and the way
these random observations are is that in
expectation its
f of T so for example again X of T could
be f of T plus additive noise with zero
mean or X of T could be just a Poisson
random variable with parameter F of T or
any such thing
so we were just the umbrella example
better brothers yes
right so okay so for example let's go
back to that umbrella example one one
model not necessarily the model but one
model could be there well there is some
notion of let's say this let's think of
T as indexed by weak
let's forget rid of it say integer time
step and F of T is the rate at which
umbrellas are supposed to be sold or the
true demand for umbrellas at time T and
the way it's going to be realized is
that every tree every time the number of
people who want to come and buy umbrella
is some Poisson random variable with
that parameter okay and you are going to
observe X of T now it's possible that
and that's based on simply based on
transactions for example if we didn't
have conversation before but thank you
for examples if C is my shelf capacity
or the number of umbrellas on one shelf
then I'm going to observe X of T which
is something like this and then from
there I know see I know the effect Li
this G of teen G of T is what I'm s
tomato maybe from G of T I would like to
go back to F of T and of course poison
is a nice function so inversion is easy
and that's and so on but if actually we
will estimate G of T well and then from
there may be vulgar F of T thank you
question
so this is a like if you think of
classical linear models which are hidden
structure then there will be again a
special case of that all right so here's
algorithm again X of T is my data here's
what I will do well I'll explain you
what the transformation is to taking
this one-dimensional data into matrix
then we'll apply the matrix estimation
method that you borrowed from literature
that we all agreed for the purpose of
the tout there's a beautiful method that
exists out there and then just do undo
transformation and that's it it's really
all you're doing is matrix estimation so
and it's as as dumb as it gets so this
is let's say my time series okay and I'm
assuming that this could be not observed
and it's okay but I'm going to sort of
put something and something would be
just let's say empty or question marks
so this is my time series I'm going to
choose some parameter L and then I'm
just simply going to divide my time
series into these non-overlapping blocks
and these would form my columns so this
is first l thing at my first column
second l things on my second column and
so on and that's it and now this is my
matrix on this matrix I will run my
matrix estimation algorithm let's call
it that produces some matrix M hat or M
and that's and then of course then I
know that of this Val in that matrix
this is a good estimation of F of 1 F of
2 and so on and it's picked arbitrarily
right now for the purpose of the
algorithm question is that how do you
pick it I'll tell you in a second there
is a one relationship that you want to
maintain okay so let's let's do that for
a second so what do you want to do is 0
make sure that the way R is the
universal choices that you will make
sure that L and T obey the relation that
L square is roughly T that is if you
have T then you have T raised to
one-third is L
and T raised to 2/3 is the other
dimension
great question so yes thank you
the question is that do I need
assumption on rank of the matrix because
the traditional literature in matrix
estimation our matrix completion
particular assumes some kind of a low
rank structure so answer is no and I'll
explain you why what we'll okay so the
this basic insight is that this matrix
the way its form if indeed F satisfies
one of those moral classes or
combination of that then this mu this
matrix would turn out to satisfy that
latent variable model that I explained
and laden with Lipschitz functions and
if the this is function class then it's
not exactly low rank but it's not too
far there is for Lipschitz functions we
know how to do matrix estimation well as
well so again remember these all of
these X's are generated innocent
expectation they're nothing but that
function f and hence there is some
relationship so it turns out that even
though there like some kind of
arbitrating yeah and so I'll come to
that in a second so let's assume for a
second that of I've chosen L well
independent of whatever choice of Alys
this matrix will satisfy latent variable
model
like you can make better good good
hold on to that for two slides or one
slide okay so in this case I'm assuming
that they're equally played space
because I'm sampling them at integer
values now of course at some integer
value I may not observe it and that's
okay
but still I will know that there is a
notion of a time unit which is what is X
I XJ X 1 I and X 2j it would be no so
I'll have to depend on F but it'll be
some transformed version of that because
what are you f is one-dimensional
function latent variable model is two
dimensional functions you'd have to do
something okay so okay let's sort of let
me paraphrase your question why would a
latent variable model be satisfied here
when I sort of organize this matrix this
way all right so quick answer now and
maybe in interest of six minutes I have
left is okay let me answer that question
at the end of the talk
thank you I should have figured out a
way to answer that briefly I'm sorry I
have not figured out that yet okay so
all right so here's the basic theorem
and again details are missing in a sense
here but let's just sort of do one thing
let's just go back to the classical
signal processing all right where I've
got let's say I've got a 1 to n
different periods and in that case
really I'm solving if it's noise free
then I'm solving system of linear
equations with two end parameters okay
because sines and cosines are fixed and
known and then of course if I would add
noise I'll need scaling which is faster
than n
when I'm thinking of additive noise what
we need in this case is T should be n
square okay not n n square so it is a
quadratic loss is this good or bad again
sort of our interest getting into this
was not we want to win a race we're
going to have a generic method that
works across class of models but I do
believe that there is something here
maybe not n but something more than n
that is needed because this kind of
theorem works for even poison like noise
well this kind of result requires you to
have additive noise so denoising
depending on noise model can be
complicated and that might require more
data ok so I don't know what's the right
lower bound here I believe that right
lower bound should be n to power alpha
where alpha is strictly greater than 1
definitely it's less than 2 but I don't
know why so that in a sense Ramesh
briefly answers at least in that context
specific model and for each class you
can figure out and for depending on
there's a formula there ok here is a one
quick experiment what we did is again we
took a nice mixture of all three models
it was additive noise and what I'm
plotting here is the fraction of data
observed randomly and when I'm plotting
on that axis is mean squared error and
again this is normalized be normalized
all data to lie in between interval
minus one and one and this is the error
that you get with our algorithm across P
this is the error that you get what I
would call baseline and baseline comes
from R and this is what you would get
using Emelia so amelia if you have not
heard of it it's one of those things
which all the empirical social
scientists swear by and it's a nice
model in the sense that they assume that
there's some notion some kind of a
Gaussian model use that to interpolate
through e/m algorithm at least it's do
it's not doing terribly here is at least
I found this more interesting so let's
see what what did vary the same time
series but now instead
observing in additive noise we're
generating a Poisson noise okay so we
made sure that so everything is positive
first and then generated a Poisson and
then this is shifted back so okay and
then what these great things are are
actual observations so as you can see
they're all over the blue is true means
or true time series and the red is the
estimation can I hope you're seeing very
little red seem to do really well and
that just to say that of there's a with
increasing P R square and our MSE are
going in the right direction
okay so that's the first question now I
have two more minutes a thank you let me
quickly go through the second and third
part again let's assume the same model
as before and now instead of just doing
imputation I want to actually forecast
there is given data to the time T I'm
gonna do predict what's gonna happen at
time T plus 1 and here you do one more
step and one more step is in addition to
doing transformation and matrix
estimation you will do what I would call
simple linear regression and then after
that you use that to do prediction okay
so just to remind ourselves this was the
transformation we did in the previous
step now I had this superscript one
which I didn't emphasize there but now I
will emphasize I could do this like this
or I could shift everything by one more
thing like starting from two or starting
from three you're starting from L okay
there so L versions of matrices
effectively a little bit shuffled I've
got L of them for each of these matrix I
will do matrix estimation and then what
I will do is that in that matrix
estimated matrix this is the last row
and these are all L minus 1 things
before that effectively for this LM in
every column and I will think of these
as features and this has target and I
will do linear regression
then let me call that be Takei and then
now I'm gonna predict forty plus one if
I CLE I'll find Kay as this because
where it lies so I'm just simply looking
for the last L minus one things and use
the right model for that that's how I'm
choosing K I go and look at my last L
minus one things then I project them on
the column space of my D noised matrix
and after that projected on that with
the projected vector I just might do in
a product and I get the value this is
nothing really complicated if I could
same as before but with this one linear
regression step now this is very this
worked really well in practice and so we
were wondering why should it work well
in practice
turns out this really interesting fact
that is last row being a linear function
or approximately linear function of all
other row for all of these latent
variable model is true and it's
remarkable that it's true at least yeah
we found proof is simple but at least it
was lots of experiments that drove us to
this conclusion and there was a there
was surprising to us and you get what
you hope for is you got error which
scales with noise this universal
constant and there's one over P which is
the missing value all right I think I'm
literally at the end of that things do
well as one would expect and the last
thing is with synthetic control I think
I'm not going to go there again it turns
out to be effectively a matrix
estimation problem but with many time
series so for example if you go back to
the previous examples where instead of
having one time citizen of your multiple
time citizen now you use multiple time
series along with the time series
structure to do estimation for the
target you could use the same method
that you just keep stacking the lags
when you do that kind of thing for the
world of synthetic control you get what
you want
and
it seems that if you did not do the
matrix estimation the traditional
methods actually do terribly that's the
only only piece of information I'll
leave and with the head that is correct
so short answer is no a long answer is
regularization can help at is in
experiments we find that we don't know
exactly when it should doing better of
course when you a smaller amount of data
that does help as you would expect but I
don't have a good conclusive answer for
that yes
of these majors completion that
Samaritan is that the rubber boots
you could reorder the roads and you
would get the same estimates so it seems
like there's some information
a good question so there's only one type
of structure that you're retaining which
is by every column has effectively put
singles recent history and so even if
you shuffle them it's not clear that so
you're really fundamentally lost things
if I'm thinking from the lens of linear
regression or any regression functions
so I don't know how to answer that
question great question maybe in
interest of next speakers time I'm gonna
[Applause]